(rock music)
- Good morning, guys.
What up, Vlog?
Monday morning, Jets game devastating.
Emotions running high.
Never wanted to care this year.
Don't know how I got suckered in.
Classic Jets.
The year that I was thrilled
to go O in 16 and be passive,
they suckered me in to break
my fuckin' heart yesterday.
That's a little energy
this Monday morning.
Bunch of business reviews,
going out to Long Island, doing a talk,
coming back and doing a wine
dinner with a bunch of people.
Think we should film a lot of that.
Did we get the approval on that?
That's gonna be really rad.
I'm sure you're about to watch that,
but the 90 day business reviews
with all the offices
and divisions of Vayner.
So really, heads down, grinding work.
We'll show you some B roll on that.
Working on a lot of the sneaker stuff,
the Gary V001 and 002's are coming.
I'm super excited about that.
Let's go.
What's up, guys?
Happy Monday, hope everybody's super well.
Fun news, putting a new
sign on the wine library.
Big ass sign one the building.
You've seen it before,
we've got it updated,
and so I'm looking for sign purveyors.
If you are a company that sells signage
that goes on buildings,
I'd like to hear from you.
Gary@vaynermedia.com, I would like
to give you some business.
Looking for the best
service and the best deals.
Keeping it simple, let's do this.
Good luck, pass it on to
your sign buddies. See ya.
The number one skill to
have in communication
is the ability to listen.
Once you deploy empathy
and listening skills,
you know what to say.
This is the biggest miss
by 99.9% of the market.
(upbeat electronic music)
Two hardcore reviews,
I'm sure Iris did some cool
time lapse and some rad music.
Now headed to Long Island for an event.
Gonna catch up on phone calls,
bunch of stuff going on there.
Good day so far.
Solid. Solid amount of work done
in the first couple hours of the day.
- [Man In Suit] Hey, Gary.
That hot wings interview.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- [Man In Suit] All those wings, man.
- Thank you, brother.
Appreciate it.
Spicy as fuck, but I'm too
mentally strong to waiver.
(gentle piano music)
All right, we're getting here,
let's get in here.
Let's see what's going on here.
Let's go.
Way back when, I did a
talk for Daymond John,
and one of his buddies asked me
to do a talk at his conference.
I said yes, so we're gonna go give a talk
at this conference now.
We'll see what this is all about.
Looking forward to it.
(applause and cheering)
- [Bryce] My name's Bryce.
- Bryce.
- [Bryce] You kind of touched
on this a little bit already,
but what do you believe holds people back
from just taking action?
- Other people's opinions.
- [Bryce] And how do you overcome that?
- By telling your mom
to go fuck themselves.
(audience laughs)
(Gary chuckles)
Bryce, I'm so hot on this, man.
I am so sad that the reason
you get a reaction like that,
is a mix between it's
funny to use the word mom
and fuck in the same sentence, right?
But it's way more true.
If you listen to the tone
of the laughs in here,
and saw what I just saw,
the truth in what I just
said is so powerful.
I am so sorry.
I am driven by gratitude.
I am grateful that my
parents were so awesome.
They never made me feel inferior. Right?
And so many of you,
whether through a sibling or a parent,
had a miserable, sad, negative parent,
who tried to impose
their negativity on you,
and misery loves company,
and it's greatest execution
is parents on kids.
That's something we never talk about.
It's not talked about enough,
and so if my legacy,
when I die, when I take me last breath,
if you asked me what I
really think I'm gonna think,
I think I'm gonna think
that I was the human being
that came along and brought
the most awareness to this conversation.
It is my absolute passion
because I've seen what
my grandma did to my dad,
and I know what my mom did to me,
and it's a big fuckin' difference, bro.
It's called happiness.
So, why do I think a lot
of you don't do shit?
Because you value other
people's opinions of you.
Why do I think you have that?
Because you weren't given
self esteem as a kid,
and you're gone the other way,
and if there's anything,
one of the biggest reasons
I act like a big shot
is because I want kids
to become fans of me,
so that I can then become
the shield for them
to have confidence to do
good things, not bad things.
Because if I'm cool,
then they're not talking about Ferrari's
and fuckin' gold watches.
They're talkin' about hard work, humility,
empathy, and kindness.
(applause)
Did you enjoy it?
- (laughs) Yeah.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Man In Red] That was a touchdown, dude.
- [Gary] It's insane that
they took that from us.
- [Man In Red] I can't believe it.
- Your 60 seconds on why people
can't really get past their fears.
- My big thing is that people's fears
are predicated on other people, right?
So they are allowing
other people's opinions,
you're allowing other people's opinions
to dictate your life.
The fear is being judged, right?
It's just classic high
school peer pressure.
You actually care about what your dad,
or mom, or grandma,
or husband, or wife,
or daughter, or son is gonna say about you
if you do this thing,
which I'm very empathetic.
I care so much about
those people in my life,
but I will not allow them
to dictate my behavior,
because ultimately I don't
want to be mad at them,
or really have this pent up resentment.
So many of you are going to be resentful,
and blame somebody else besides yourself.
It's your fault that you're
not doing your thing,
and so the reason I think it's happening
is the judgment of others.
It's the same shit from fourth
and fifth grade that we develop,
and a lot of it has to do
with the parents that you had,
and so I implore everybody to understand,
you only have one life,
and it's much better to live it
for yourself than somebody else.
- Four hundred trillion to one.
- That's it, baby.
- Appreciate it.
- Take care. Buh bye.
Talk is done, we got some
good content in there.
Super excited about it. See ya.
Hey guys, some breaking
news out of the tech world,
looks like Facebook just acquired TBH,
which has been an app that is
a positive focused polling app
that I've been noticing ranking
very high on the app store.
Here in a TechCrunch article,
they're saying TBH has
scored five million downloads
and 2.5 million daily active
users in the past nine weeks,
and it's an app that
allows people to answer
kind hearted multiple choice
questions about friends.
Positivity on the offense,
kind of the reverse of
what we saw from Secret,
and Wisper, and anonymous negative,
which is what you normally get,
they created restrictions that
made it anonymous positive,
but the biggest reason
I'm jumping in here,
and I've said it, I have great ambition
to be known as an all time
great day trader of attention,
right, but nobody in the
corporate world today does
a better job on paying
attention to attention better
than Mark Zuckerberg and
the team at Facebook.
Whether it was their
acquisition of Instagram,
and even going back to Friend Finder?
Uh, no, what was it that they bought?
Not Friend Finder, maybe Friend Find?
Oh geez, I can't remember,
but going back to all their acquisitions,
obviously Instagram, obviously
their bid on Snapchat,
FriendFeed (snaps fingers),
FriendFeed, remember that?
I think it's FriendFeed,
but nonetheless, thanks Iris.
(Iris laughs)
It's so much more fun to
have Iris here than D-Rock,
ah but I love,
anyway nonetheless,
FriendFeed is right actually,
which is more talent and infrastructure,
but attention whether it's been Instagram,
or Snapchat, or WhatsApp,
or the way they think about VR and Oculus,
I'm just obsessed with
their ability to do so,
and now another purchase
from the Facebook family over
at Menlo Park, TBH.
They're gonna let it run by
itself, the article says.
I haven't even read the article,
just wanna give my first quick take.
I wanna definitely do some
more breaking news quick takes.
What does this mean?
It means one thing,
that Zucks, and Cheryl,
and the rest of Facebook mafia
does it better than anybody
in arbitrage and attention.
Sometimes they'll miss,
sometimes they'll win,
but they're always gonna play
in buying up attention as a platform.
I try to trade it as a creative,
and as a media planner,
and as a personality.
I see what they're doing, and I like it.
(laid back music)
It's unbelievable.
Let me set my piece.
So we're shooting my new K-Swiss sneakers,
and Babin literally forgot the sneakers
at the office this morning.
I don't know if we caught it, Iris,
I don't think so.
So before you started filming,
I told Tyler literally for
you to give them to Avy,
and be like, we got it,
we got it, and literally right now,
when I was like, "where
is the other pair?"
he's like, "I forgot them at the office,"
I was literally like, "I fuckin' knew it,"
and let me tell you why,
VaynerNation, I knew it,
because we are unbelievable,
unbelievable at all the hard shit, right?
Like everyone's so stunned by our ability
to do so much shit that we do,
but we suck shit at the most basic shit,
like bringing the fucking sneakers
to the shoot for the shoot
of the fucking sneakers.
- Yeah.
- You're shooting my sneakers,
and you forgot the sneakers?
- Basically.
(Iris laughs)
- Thank you, Iris,
for the proper reaction.
- The four people that like me more
than D-Rock just flipped.
(laughing)
- Yeah, like I've literally
been working the last month
to get you six fans,
and now back to fuckin' zero.
- Yeah.
- I'm not shooting with these.
I'm upset.
I'm not doing it.
We'll have to figure it out tomorrow.
- All right.
- You ever hear of the term cut your nose
to spite your face?
That was the example.
(Iris laughs)
Babin.
- [Babin] He told me,
and I was like getting shit together,
and I just walked out.
- [Gary] That was cool.
(laughing)
Now Tyler's not picking it up.
- Say what's up to my friend Chris.
- [Gary] Okay, is that
why you're hanging out?
- Hey, it's nice to meet
you. Very nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you. How are you?
- Very good.
- [Gary] Good, real pleasure.
Hi.
- Hi, Logan.
- [Gary] Logan?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Gary.
- [Gary And Logan] Nice to meet you.
- [Babin] He's jumped in on
a lot of Vayner Sports stuff,
done a lot of video
stuff for the athletes.
- Thank you, real pleasure.
Oh, you're the Florida dude?
Oh, I know exactly who you are.
Yeah, that's awesome, man.
It's really nice to meet you.
- I appreciate that.
- [Gary] Awesome, real pleasure.
How are things?
- Good. First time in the city,
so it's been really cool.
- So what, the plan was like...
- No, I was like,
we're doing a photo shoot.
- I love it.
- [Babin] Because I fucked up, so.
- Guys, Babin has totally fucked up
this entire episode of DailyVEE.
- [Babin] Yeah.
- But at least we got to meet.
- Absolutely.
- Do you want a job?
I've got one short on my video crew.
- Yeah, I'll replace him.
I got it.
- I gotta do a call.
Nice meeting you, man.
It would have been good if you figured
it out 19 minutes ago, instead of,
Iris, please make sure
you're filming all this.
Like don't get caught,
yeah, you gotta be.
- [Man On Phone] Gary?
- [Gary] Yes, good afternoon.
How ya doin'?
(gentle music)
Hey, Vlog.
I'm doing my one anti-social move.
Usually before events,
I just try to get my
last minute work into it,
and so that's what I'm doing.
- [Man In Hat] I'm sorry,
but I was just reading
a book called Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
(Gary laughs)
So sorry I'm a few minutes late, man.
- [Gary] How are ya?
- [Man In Hat] I love your books.
- Thank you, brother.
Thank you so much, brother.
So happy you're here.
- [Man In Glasses] Hey,
they're all doing all this other shit,
and I'm like, damn,
when I was a kid and
looking at these guys,
none of those guys were
fuckin' hip, but now.
- No 42 year old,
you know, I have a
signature shoe come out.
- Congrats, by the way.
- Thank you.
Like, that's not how we grew up.
A businessman was a suit, you know.
It's crazy.
- You are like totally hilarious.
- I'm cooler at 42 than I was at 24,
and it's not even fucking close.
- You know, I feel the same way.
I'm 39. I feel the exact same way.
It's such an interesting time for all us.
- It's crazy. It's crazy.
It speaks to truth.
- But I feel like that truth
didn't even exsist before.
- It didn't, because
it wasn't a truth yet,
because the seed of hip
hop didn't scale yet.
It was a baby.
- Yeah, because I feel
like I wouldn't even be,
if it didn't scale,
I wouldn't even be still doing it.
- You know what it would be?
You know what it is?
It's you and I, probably,
if we were 20 years older,
would have been rock and roll kids,
because that's what it represented.
- [Man In Glasses] Right.
- That's all.
- Now we're just like...
- I just like our thing better.
I'm really glad that it's that inclusive,
and that authentic, and it's cool.
Yeah, I totally agree with you.
It's wild to watch.
- When you go on stage though,
I feel like you have almost like a,
actually to use this as an example,
talking about two people,
I feel like it's like watching
like DMC at the Gardon in like '86.
When you come on stage,
you don't come on like to talk,
you come on to kill it.
- Kill. I'm completely
affected by those acts,
and Richard Pryor, and Eddie Murphy.
Like I'm completely affected by,
you know, early hip
hop acts fucked with me
because it wasn't that entertaining.
Like rap was funny that way.
- Yeah.
- Like I was always more about like,
they fuckin' deer point, and they kill it,
and there's words, what they meant.
- Right.
- The entertainment value
is a little more difficult.
Like the guy in the
back is like, yeah yeah.
Like it's a funny little thing.
I think you're right.
- Do you think,
one thing I'm working on,
actually I'm curious
what you think about it,
is I'm creating this content series
where I'm actually going
to talking to CEOs,
and CMOs about how hip hop inspired them
to create their successful businesses.
- Listen, you probably heard it,
because I know you've
seen some of my stuff,
I think hip hop is the foundation of our,
you should 100% explain that.
- [Man In Glasses] I think I'm like
the perfect guy to do that,
because I'm kind of like straddling both.
- [Gary] You'll own that.
- [Man In Glasses] Nice.
- When you're done with it,
come and see me.
We haven't hung out in awhile,
let me look at it and give you some sense.
- [Man In Glasses] Cool.
Would you be down to talk for it?
Like to do an interview for it?
- For real.
- [Man In Glasses] We just
talk about rap lyrics.
I think it'd be fun.
- We should spend more time together.
- You have a great team of
people working with you now.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Wine Connoisseur] So
basically here's what I did.
I've decanted four of each of these.
- [Gary] Okay.
- At 11:00.
- Love it.
- I decanted this one at 11:00,
but I brought extras of these
that were not decanted at 11:00
so they could pop these,
because what'll happen is
you get all the minerality.
- Of course.
- And all the very complex way they
have four different spots
in the armitage for that.
So anyways, you get just a crack here.
This is Keller,
and this softens things up a little bit.
So basically what I did
was I brought stuff decanted at 11,
and I brought stuff that
hasn't been opened yet.
So I figured we'd do
a little side by side.
- [Gary] Mix it up.
Be fun. Be fun.
- Just give them a little experience.
- Learn.
- What do you think?
- Great, I'm a huge fuckin' fan
of their wines for a long time.
- [Wine Connoisseur] There you go.
Now this is Jolee.
- I had him on Wine Library TV.
- Oh you did?
- [Gary] It was the best
interview I ever had.
- No way.
- [Gary] I love him.
- I hear he's a whack
job, I've never met him.
- Whack fuckin' job.
It was suppose to be 15, 20 minutes.
It was an hour and 13 minutes.
- Whoa.
- I'll never forget, I missed my,
I didn't even go to the
city for a tasting I
was supposed to go to,
because we had such a great time.
I mean, I'm obsessed
with this guy's stuff.
It's gonna be interesting.
- It's gonna be very interesting.
- [Gary] To see how they react to it.
How are you?
- [Danny] Hi, I'm Danny.
- [Gary] Gary.
- [Danny] Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, Danny.
Cool stuff.
- So this guy.
- Cool ex motor oil.
- I did decant them at 11,
because I did need to get
rid of some of that girostal.
- That stuff.
- I knew there was gonna
be a little too much.
- For everybody, yeah.
This is fuckin' gangster.
What's crazy about this, it's so crazy.
So fun to get back into the wine kick.
Brother, I'm glad we did this.
- Let's rock and roll, man.
- The two gentlemen on the bookend.
In the big high chairs,
in the arm chairs, I'm sorry.
Matt and Dave said, let's talk about wine,
because that was organic,
and then Gary said, "Souza."
Well, actually Souz.
They call me Souz.
"Come over here.
"Let's do a wine dinner."
So, I've been working on this,
obviously with two ridiculous schedules,
and all of yours,
and we're here today to do that, so enjoy.
- I mean, what's going on
on Instagram right now is,
I would argue, grossly underestimated
by the majority of us,
maybe including me, who spends eight hours
a day trying to figure it out.
We've got culture living
through this platform
at a scale that I think makes people,
I just don't think people understand
what's actually happening,
which is the amount of
actual net attention
on this platform speaks to a time where,
looking around the room,
a lot of us grew up,
when there was less channels, you know.
You know, yo MTV raps.
Looking around the room,
knowing a lot of people around the room,
so impactful, right?
White kid in medicine, New Jersey,
that was the propaganda I
needed to get into the culture.
I just think Instagram is
stunningly underestimated.
Did you see what he did today?
The guy trades attention.
He bought TBH today.
Like every behavior out of his actions
is buying and trading attention.
That's all he does.
I met him in 2008.
- [Diner] What's TBH?
- It's this kids app.
Do you remember Secret and Wisper?
- [Diner] Yeah.
- Yik Yak, all these viral apps,
the reason they all failed
is when you were anonymous,
the lowest common denominator
of human behavior kicks in,
and it's really fun to
say something anonymous
about your neighbor,
until somebody says something about you,
and then everybody leaves.
TBH went the other way.
It was anonymous,
but it was forced positivity.
So you would do a poll and
little things about people,
but you had to say something good,
which created virality,
because people liked hearing
nice things about themselves
from anonymous sources.
It became huge with teenagers.
It's the number six app in
the app store right now.
- Gary, he's a brother
from another mother,
super amazing dude, love him so much,
responsible for me being here today,
and I really appreciate him,
and being here tonight.
Thank you, Gary.
- [Gary] Thanks, brother.
I gotta run.
- [Diner] I have to give you something.
- Please, next.
Reach out.
Robert and I are now heading to Harlem,
because that's how we do.
We're gonna do a little bit of chef,
little Marcus Samuelsson,
little Harlem action, Robert?
- Yeah, Marcus Samuelsson,
we've been involved with
food and wine all week.
Listen, he's like can't
come to your amazing dinner,
but you gotta come to mine.
I've never invited anybody,
but I wanted you and Gary to come.
- Harlem.
- Like love you.
- [Gary] We know a lot of connectors.
Like we're all living life.
The amount of connectors who
don't have intent to trade
on the connection in the
short term barely exist,
and that's why I appreciate Souz.
Hey guys, wrapping up,
gonna send Iris home,
because it's late already,
it's 10:00, and we've got two
hours here at the Red Rooster.
Bunch of people from Food and Wine,
gonna see some old friends,
gonna do some networking.
You know, no matter where you get to,
you've always gotta do a little hunting,
a little farming, a little networking,
a little shaking hands,
a little kissing babies.
Just very grateful for
the life I'm living,
and more importantly for the attention
that you guys give me,
and so I hope you have a wonderful day.
Iris did a great job today,
it was a great day.
See you guys later.